Zimbabwe has been an uncomfortable place
to live for much of the last two decades
residents of mapo-gu a township east of
Harare know this all too well access to
running water in their homes has been a
dream and have had to rely on boreholes
mostly provided by foreign donors it's
been like this for something like ten
years now we have to wake up early
around 4:00 a.m. or 3:00 a.m. for you to
get water like you see this kill you we
have to wake up early so that you get
enough water it's really painful and
it's really not a good life for us to do
so much of Zimbabwe's infrastructure
fell into decline during Robert Mugabe's
rule and the former president's failure
to deal with corruption and the economy
has had a devastating impact on the
country's public health sector it's very
difficult to get permission to film
inside a hospital here so I secretly
recorded this video on my cell phone
this is one of the biggest hospitals in
the country and it's astonishing to see
a facility relying on old equipment it's
largely under-resourced and its staff or
overwhelmed medical practitioners often
can't administer treatment because of a
lack of resources dr. Edgar Munez he
tells me it's hard to have to walk away
from a patient who can't afford health
care a medical bill of $10 can be too
much for some Zimbabweans is very much
heartbreaking and draining to look at
your patients when they are suffering
and sometimes you have to ask them if
they do have God so they're able to sell
a house or for them to be able to afford
the service that we are providing and
yet this is a public institution
sometimes you lose so many patients from
illness that is defeatable Zimbabwe was
once the breadbasket of southern Africa
boasting some of the best infrastructure
in the region today the vast majority of
people here have no jobs and the
country's infrastructure has been
crumbling for years many of the railway
networks are no longer in use
some roads haven't been serviced in
years with the persistent decline in
Zimbabwe's political and economic
situation millions have left the country
in search of greener pastures many of
them young and skilled further
impoverishing an already battered nation